the job will change the location will
change the position will change the
salary will change the thing that won't
change is your requirement to actually
do some work and be able to work hard
and to know that you've got limits that
are way way way beyond what you need to
do and that's kind of like a superpower
because most of the people don't have
that you discuss masculinity intimacy
openness so curious your thoughts on
pegging
once your friends welcome back it is a
350 000 subscriber q a episode uh this
300 000 was missed because we blasted
through that so quickly that i didn't
have time to do one uh and now we're at
350. i have no idea what to think about
the last month and a bit of attention
and growth and stuff
so welcome if you are new here and if
you're a long time listener thank you
for sharing and liking and
being a part of the cult for all this
time and whatnot i asked for questions
off instagram and twitter and locals and
youtube community and there was nearly a
thousand so thank you to assistant ben
as well for filtering them all and we've
picked some of the best ones and i'm
gonna try and get around to as many as i
can
let's get into it sam weatherall do you
believe in semen retention
nofap superpowers
uh
no
no i've
as far as i can see nofap is most
beneficial to people that are
pathological fappers right that can't
keep their hand off the penis and if
that is you and you're fapping it you
know three or four times a day you are
going to have kind of a superpower
because you've just freed up
maybe two hours of your day to do stuff
that isn't fapping uh outside of that
the levitation and the women being able
to smell the pheromones and stuff
i'm less convinced
sarah russo what advice would you give
to a young career-driven woman in her
20s
take no one else's word for it
i would say that you get to define how
it is that you're going to live and
presuming that what some
article newspaper
cultural movement friend has done as
being like the thing that you have to do
is wrong just continually reassess
where am i at am i doing what i want to
do is this making me happy is this the
path that i'm supposed to be on
you won't go far wrong if you do that
and this would be the same for a guy as
well um but yeah there is a temptation
with young career-driven women to have
kind of a sunk cost fallacy here that
like this is my identity and i'm going
to completely adhere myself to this um
just keep on checking and maybe you will
want to stay a career-driven woman for
the rest of your life and maybe you
won't but as long as you're doing the
introspection you'll be able to course
correct on root
isaac
medjangos
who would you like to have on next can
you create a form on your website for us
to request guests we'd like to see on
the pod so there already is one and it's
chriswilex.com
contact so
go there and you can send me whoever you
want um i always appreciate getting
feedback and suggestions from you guys
sometimes they're fantastic other times
they're
less fantastic but sometimes they're
really good who i'd like to have on next
what i really want to do with the show
after the jordan peterson sort of
special 4k big production cinematic
thing i'm really keen to try and do
maybe
two between two and four of those a year
so find a very big guest and fly out to
see them or fly them to see me
and create something that's really
visually beautiful uh so
next on the hit list i think
would be jocker willink i've only half a
degree of separation away from him with
some mutuals and i think that it's been
a little while since we've seen
something like really dramatic and
beautiful with him
plus i love his content and i think that
his style of talking really lends itself
to that super intense cinematic
like very very
um beautiful look so
if you know jocker willink tell him to
get in touch or i'm going to continue
grinding away trying to find my way to
him but yeah that's that's what i think
i'd like to do next as a
a big sort of project and then maybe
across the year there's you know like
between two and four of these special
bigger edition episodes
and that can kind of be the thing that
can be one of the the big growth
strategies but also one of the things
that kind of makes the show special and
makes it stand out because i don't think
many other people are doing that
max h wilson what's your friend time uh
i think it was
slate seven minutes like seven or eight
minutes uh and i made such a
huge meal of that workout so for those
of you that don't know fran is 21 15
nine repetitions of thrusters
uh 42 kilos uh and pull-ups
and uh it is
for me it's just hell because you can't
go unbroken uh
seven in a bit minutes of just just pain
and then panting and and complaining and
making a meal of it
megan curry what's your thoughts on male
and female platonic relationships
they are difficult
in my experience
uh if you only had one party that would
be able to get attracted it would be
kind of difficult but the fact that you
have two and that one you can either
have
one person or both people that
want the relationship to no longer be
platonic
it is very very hard i think to make
work that's not to say that men and
women can't be friends and absolutely
they can especially you know like work
colleagues and stuff like that
but
you i think it's
right to be careful about which members
of the opposite sex you become friends
with because if you develop feelings for
them or they develop feelings for you
that can lead to quite a bit of
suffering and awkwardness
so just be careful that's all i'm saying
martha tits or ass
um so i was a boob guy throughout almost
all of my 20s and then toward the end of
my 20s i've switched and now i'm a bum
guy and that if anybody tells you that
people can't change
there you go there's some proof for you
martin
do you think the currently pretty
immature and toxic manosphere scene will
evolve into a more healthy and
culturally accepted men's movement
similar to second wave feminism in its
day
man i've never thought about that before
i have never thought that the current
version of the manosphere or whatever
is like just the first iteration of it
and that maybe you're going to have
another wave that comes through now
perhaps we've seen this going from
pickup artistry neil strauss
stuff
pivoting into what is now more like red
pill evolutionary psychology
manosphere men's rights black pill in
selling stuff um i
would absolutely hope so and i think
that if you were to kind of have a big
clean out of all of the toxic elements
and all of the shitty elements uh that
would make for a much better
experience for both men that are trying
to learn from it and from the women that
are hopefully benefiting from the men
that learn from it
so yeah that would be that'd be
fantastic i really hope so
uh mindful mitch your biggest internal
struggle if any as your channel has
grown
that's a good question um
i so
the last
year last month and a bit we've done 10
million plays and about 80 000 subs on
youtube
and it is
you do feel the scrutiny like i i feel
the increased number of eyes on me which
is strange because that's what you
wanted right i'm doing the show to reach
more people to get more exposure to have
amazing conversations that interest me
and hopefully benefit the lives of
everybody that listens or watches
but when it happens very intensely you
are
super super conscious of all of the
extra scrutiny and eyes and attention
that's on you and
i i don't know it's just something that
you become aware of you you are very
very conscious of the fact that there
are so many people watching
um but it's the same as anything right
like if you
change if you moved cities or if you
went from being in a relationship to
being single or if you lost a loved one
or whatever but any sort of quick change
in life you're going to notice it and
this is kind of no different but that's
that's the one of the bigger internal
struggles that
i don't know quite how to deal with that
increased level of
attention yet uh and because we spent so
much time doing the show
with barely any attention on it you know
like it's been we've been going for four
years and have done more plays in the
last
like three or four months than in all of
the three in a bit years up until then
beforehand so
yeah that's one of the things i'm going
to be working on at learning over the
next few months
sean powelling
what did you eat when you went for
dinner with jordan peterson uh so i
spent a week with jordan in new york
after the episode
and it was obviously beef every single
meal
like
i i felt like i would be spitting in the
face of everybody sat around the table
when everyone else ordered beef and i
was like
look at the look at the mac and cheese
please um so no i had beef a lot of beef
uh mj delaney fit
is asceticism a big lie
very good question and
yes i think it is i think that most
people that are
recounting
the trappings of the modern world and
saying i don't need
money or success or status or whatever
i think that for most people it's just a
cope
i think that that is their way of not
having to compete um i spoke about the
inner citadel which is this isaiah
berlin concept
and i'm pretty sure that asceticism for
most people is there in a citadel by
saying that they never cared about money
or status or
growth or friends or whatever it might
be uh they don't need to
face the potential pain
of not winning at that game i also think
that mgtow
and that whatever the female equivalent
is
like pig tower like the pink pill or
whatever it's called i think that's a
cope in the same way as well i think
that that's a lot of people's inner
citadels right that they just
it's less about wanting to be on your
own and more about not wanting to be
hurt by being in relationships with
people of the opposite sex
mad hat matt what are your goals for
modern wisdom in 2022 uh i want to
really work hard on growing the audio
plays so if you're watching this on
youtube and you're not subscribed on
audio you can get the episodes 10 hours
earlier every single day when they go up
they're available 10 hours beforehand on
spotify or apple podcasts and there will
be a link in the show notes below and in
the comment so you can just follow that
through press subscribe and it supports
the show and it makes me happy which is
great
i really really want to grow that
because that means that i would then be
able to get a producer on board
which would help me to just free up some
of my time like this is
so full time i
look for the guests so i'm doing
scouting for guests i'm scheduling for
guests i'm researching i'm recording and
then doing all of the audio editing on
the back end i do all of the promotion
on the back end of that the youtube
briefs and the asset sheets for dean all
of the clips and the asset sheets for
that as well
that's all me still and i it's kind of
becoming
well it's not kind of like it is pretty
unsustainable i think at this work rate
um and the reason that i'm able to
continue going at the moment is that
i've got this vision that hopefully soon
i'll be able to delegate that to
somebody else so i would look forward to
bringing some talented producer in that
could work full-time and look after all
of that stuff and then it means that i
can finally actually spend time doing
something which isn't
all of the little bits and i can focus
on the show and researching and reading
i don't spend i haven't had that much
time to read stuff aside from what i
need to do for the show so that would be
the goals grow the audio channels so
if you want to help by subscribing and
listening
please do
louis keenan13 do you believe everything
happens for a reason in your life
i'm really anti this i i don't like the
term that things happen for a reason
because i think it takes away
the beauty of the agency that you had to
make things go well let me give you an
example so
imagine that you break your leg and upon
breaking your leg you end up losing your
job or not being able to stick in your
job and then you change and you end up
moving to a new city and getting a new
job and that job's even better
you could say well you know i broke my
leg for a reason everything happens for
a reason
but the reverse of that is
you had something really shitty happen
to you
and you overcame it and made the
situation even better on the back end of
a move to a new city and a new job and a
broken leg like that's the more
beautiful framing for me so it
things happening for a reason in
retrospect
seems to take a little bit of the um
the pride that you can have in what you
did like don't attribute your successes
to a higher power they're yours
you were the one that made them happen
so you can own them
harry keenan
37 have you tried to get naval on the
pod uh yes i have i reached out to him
probably about two years ago now and he
said that he was taking a sabbatical it
was just after the rogan episode taking
a sabbatical and i haven't pushed again
like he would be between him and sam
harris those are my two
must gets
uh and
you know if it happens it happens i look
forward to him maybe re-entering the
world of doing podcasts at some point
and
we'll see but if i did i would be
that would be one that i'd be very very
happy about and would
100 be a you know 6k cinema crew fly
them out to wherever he is thing
harrison matthews regret going on love
island question mark uh not at all not
at all it was a yolo you know there's
not many things you can do
that only
like less than a thousand people have
done uh i think there's more people have
been to the top of everest than have
been on love island and i'm not equating
the two
however my point is that there's just
not many things left that only a few
people have done
and it was fun and i was 27 at the time
so yeah it was sweet
uh freddie bull hi chris eve psych
mental health question
do you think there's a mismatch between
the anti-workaholic
pro-men's mental health idea you
discussed with matt rudd and the desire
to be in that top 20 of men needed to be
successful with women it seems the
mental health episodes are saying
release the tiller careless and the eve
psych episodes saying work until you're
earning 200 000 pounds and have five gym
sessions a week where do you think the
balance is between the two
dude that is an absolute monster of a
question uh
thank you
yes this is one of the core tensions
that we have in life right that
i genuinely do believe that releasing
the tiller and just allowing yourself to
be carried forward
is a
fundamental foundation that will make
you more happy
that being said we can't get away from
the fact that there are certain
quantifiable metrics of success that you
want to have in life in order to give
you access to
objectively better modes of living right
being rich might not make you happy but
being poor can make you miserable so the
balance between the two is something
that we all need to find and this is one
of the tensions between those two in
fact i would say
for most people that are you know in the
western world and living in all right
the
standardized life a good standard life
this is
the tension right how much do i want to
push and work hard and how much do i
want to enjoy now the goal is to be able
to get those two things to align over
the top you want to be able to have the
thing that you push and work hard at to
be the thing that you're able to release
the tiller at so you could imagine um
sports stars would be a good example of
this that they express themselves and
they're in the moment and they find flow
doing the thing that also gains some
status um
this being said you can make the work
hard until you're earning
money and
go to the gym and do stuff like that you
can make all of that easier by trying to
do things that you genuinely enjoy so if
you find a gym routine that you actually
fundamentally enjoy to do
you're not going to think twice about
going to the gym five sessions a week
you're going to want to go 10 sessions a
week and you're going to have to hold
yourself back so i would continue to
explore with what it is that you do to
earn money and side hustles that you
also do to earn money and your training
and your charisma training and other
stuff and your personal development
until you find the thing that you're
going to genuinely enjoy and then that's
going to
allow you to care less because your
program is going to carry you forward um
but that's a an awesome question and
attention i think a lot of people feel
uh
gee
14
g14 did you have to pay jordan peterson
to get on the podcast no no that is not
the way it works i
i've never heard of people there
probably are people that do podcasts
where they pay their guests to come on
or something but it's never the way it's
worked on this show
anger panda good name uh did you find it
difficult transitioning from party boy
background into the thoughtful
productive human you are now and if so
what were the biggest difficulties
advice for an ex-party addict trying to
put their life right please
um yeah it it is strange because the
things that you used to hold yourself
used to have as values and what you
um considered to be something valuable
that you did like who you knew or what
girl you'd slept with the last previous
week or how many people came up to you
on a night out or how successful your
events were or whatever
all of that no longer serves you so you
think okay well if that's not the thing
that i genuinely value
what is the thing that i genuinely value
and that's a very scary question so
changing a change of values and what you
value in yourself is one of the biggest
difficulties that you need to overcome
the things that you used to value no
longer you no longer do
your friend group
is probably going to change because
you're going to be doing different
things um definitely one of the biggest
bits of advice would be try and do
something that puts you in a place like
the sort of person that you want to be
so i wanted to be someone that had a
more holistic
view of fitness so i started doing
crossfit and i started doing
wai tai and fighting because i thought
well these people will be more
all-encompassing there will be more on
their diet they're going to be training
harder which means they're going to
party less they're probably going to
have good social lives because they're
in a gym which is the training
methodology is focused around a communal
approach as opposed to an individual
approach um so look at different friend
groups assess your values and think
about where you want to go um
consider trying to make some fundamental
changes to your routine consider going
sober for an extended period of time you
know six months of sobriety is going to
force you to find other things to do
with your life especially if you're
partying regularly so those would be
some suggestions
apple dom
you discuss masculinity intimacy
openness so curious your thoughts on
pegging
not for me dom
thanks
libby rose as a single child do you wish
to have children if so how many do you
wish to have and why
yeah i am i keep saying this i can't
wait to be a dad
i really really can't wait to um
i
would
probably want i think three children
that seems to be
between two and three seems to be sort
of optimal for the child's development
um i also know that
you know i i
very much appreciate
that
more children is harder work but i also
think that to support the child's uh
upbringing probably having a couple of
siblings around is a good idea you know
you struggle to socialize kids as much
when they're on their own uh versus if
they've got siblings that they can
constantly play with
i always think about what it would have
been like if i'd had uh
brothers or sisters and you know turned
out relatively okay longer term uh but
yeah it's i think probably about two or
three um
i can't wait it's gonna be a huge
challenge that i'm absolutely definitely
not emotionally ready for uh but it's
gonna be fun
uh fernanda
cervantes
top five or ten books you recommend i
can give you a list of 100 actually my
reading list modern wisdom reading list
is available and it's free and you can
get it somewhere
up here or by going to chriswilex.com
books it's 100 that you need to read
before you die and they've all got
summaries and i tell you what i think
about them and why i like them and
there's links to just go and get them
straight away and it's free chris will x
dot com slash books
uh
carl dorington
question eddie hull or thor who you got
dude i've seen some
sparring footage on the well some like
pad work footage of eddie hall
and it doesn't look good
like it really doesn't look good and i
saw a video today of him and thor
in a some
corner shop looks like some 7-eleven
somewhere and they're kicking off at
each other and eddie's really lost him
is
sort of cool and maybe that's just all
for the cameras but
i
want eddie to win
but i feel like thor might have it uh
one thing that we can all agree on is
their transformation both of their body
transformations is mental absolutely
insane
jojo mclaugh any lessons learnt this
year so far and how to deal with others
opinions of you
uh
yeah i mean we're only into what march
but
yeah i would i would say that
there's been uh a little bit of pushback
around some of the guests that i've had
on the show um
and
that the this increased scrutiny has
given
people that followed the show or people
that had an idea of who i was or what i
was trying to do the show for um to
really kind of steam in and try and
i don't know say that
let's say that
i'm supposed to be some pretty boy
gateway drug right to the alt-right
the presumption there would have to be
that i'm doing
endless episodes about how to perfect
your running form or about the best rep
ranges to gain muscle or about how to
survive productivity dysmorphia just
like bottomless numbers of
life hacks episodes and like nerdy nerdy
bits and pieces like that meanwhile what
i'm actually doing is like rabidly
scratching myself under the table with
like gripping onto things just not being
able to wait until i get my hands on
some new culture war problem
one of the most annoying things that you
can do to people is
disprove
their presumption of what they thought
you were now sometimes you do this with
a friend when they thought that you were
a friend and you do something bad and
they go that really really hurt one of
the reasons is that you've broken their
view that they had of you now similarly
there are people on the internet that
presume that you're part of one side or
one tribe or they thought that they had
you in a particular box and if you do
something that their version of you
wouldn't have done they get very very
upset
um so the how to deal with others
opinions of you and the lessons learned
this year are kind of the same question
for me because there's been a lot more
scrutiny and i'm not 100 sure about how
to deal with it and i think as well
it's it's just a strange thing to have
happen like the human system is not
designed to have 10 million people we
did
1.3 million hours
of content watched that doesn't include
audio in the last four weeks
what that's like so i think we worked it
out 200 years of
uninterrupted content that's been viewed
i don't know what to think about that
and that means that you're going to have
more and more and more people giving
their opinion so the main thing that i
think i've learned is that as your
platform grows and as you reach more and
more people
you have to take input less and less
seriously over time
originally when you start something you
need to take or you can afford to take
the people who are contributing with you
know you can actually take the time to
read what they're saying you can presume
that they're saying in good faith
because the audience is so small that
most of the people who watch are
probably only there because they
genuinely do have an investment in you
or maybe they're your friends or they're
kind of part of a perry social circle
that you've got
however as that grows
tim ferriss has this thing where he
talks about how um million to one odds
happen eight times a day in new york
because there's eight million people
that live there so there's million to
one odds that have happened ten times in
the last four weeks on the show um
dealing with others opinions of you
just do the thing that you think you're
supposed to do as well as you can do it
and that's it so a lot of people would i
don't know give their opinions and say
that i should have done things better or
worse or whatever and that's fine but
i've really given it a good shot and
that means that i'm kind of immune to it
well look like maybe it would have been
great if i'd said this or ask that or
push back in this way
but i didn't
and i didn't think of it at the time and
maybe i'll do it again in future i'll
learn from that and try and do it better
but yeah do the thing that you're here
to do as well as you can it doesn't
really matter what other people's
opinions of you are
rjld would you ever have someone
non-famous on your podcast yes i do all
the time uh i look forward to bringing
people like uh anna codriorado you know
who's written a book but has like a
moderate online following or adam lane
smith or a vincent haranam you know
people who are basically like closet
heroes absolute monsters but within a
niche
and then giving them a platform this is
the coolest thing and this is the
coolest thing that rogan's been able to
do you know he's made
rogan's made people's careers he made
lex friedman to a large degree joker
willing david goggins jordan peterson
brett weinstein eric weinstein you know
you can
be a platform for people who
absolutely deserve to have an audience
because they're talented or they're
brilliant or they're interesting or
they're funny
but as of yet they haven't done that
because for almost
all of the come up on any sort of
platform what you're doing is you're
asking other people for favors you're
saying
i want you
david sinclair douglas murray carl
benjamin whatever person who has way
more clout than me i want to kind of
steal i want to slip stream you and hold
on to your coattails for a little bit um
and then after a little while
you realize well
my platform's got to the stage where i
don't
just need to do that i can actually be
that platform for someone else
and that's the coolest thing that makes
me so happy you know to find some
awesome
underground
monster and then just say look go and
put your brilliance out there go into
bogle perfect example wrote a twitter
thread that went absolutely insane once
he's just a dude he's just like a
computer science dude out of nowhere i
brought him on smashed it one of my
favorite episodes of last year
brilliant
liam
michael henderson your personal
experiences slash opinion of monogamy
uh i think it's right for most people i
think
the
trends around non-monogamy are
as yet unproven to me
generally as a
even a medium-term strategy and my
personal experiences of monogamy are
vast and mostly littered with failures
um
but not always
uh
charlie
h
cooksey why do you rate airpods yet used
wired earphones
[ __ ] this is such
a smart insight um so the reason that i
use these which is literally just a pair
of the old style aux cable
uh apple
headphones which you used to get with a
an iphone but you can now buy on amazon
is because when you're using the
recording software that i use
and all the full setup that i have for
recording the podcast with this
microphone
bluetooth headphones have a non-zero
chance of [ __ ] up and i just find
that being wired in
makes very little change in terms of the
quality but means that nothing ever goes
wrong in a audio setting
however i am aware that me being a
such a evangelist for airpods edward
pros
and then not putting them on to
recording i
appreciate the hypocrisy
uh right some of the questions from the
locals community if you want to join
that you can go to
modernwisdom.locals.com
there's over 3000 people in there that
like to show and think about the stuff
that we're talking about today
eloise
salil
hey chris do you think you'll ever do a
live show slash meet and greet one day
i would absolutely love to um i've been
in talks very sort of minor talks about
potentially doing a book or a couple of
books
and if i did that i would 100 be looking
at doing some um
shows off the back of that doing a live
tour
meet and greets i was considering doing
one during south by southwest but
i'm kind of nervous to do one a little
bit because what if no one shows up that
would suck
um
so yeah i mean i probably should try and
do one and just swallow my ego and see
what happens or maybe do one with
someone else maybe do one with zak
talander out here and then if it fails
then we can kind of both blame each
other and say that each other doesn't
have a big enough audience um but yeah
if i can get past my fear of putting on
a meet and greet and then no one showing
up uh i would love to i did i've been to
a few meet and greets here for other
people's things since i've been in
austin
and they're so fun it's just a group of
people that all know the same content
and talk about stuff so it has been
great i should
i should get over myself and probably do
that uh sean rambles was there a
specific if not too personal reason you
moved to austin or are you just riding
the wave of life
very much just riding the wave
uh i like it out here it's the middle of
march and 27 degrees celsius glorious
sunshine
and my gym is a seven minute walk and i
can record from here and go out for
dinner on a night time and there's
things to do and everybody's into health
and fitness and it's it's great i really
really do enjoy it
plus i was kind of tethered to the uk
for a very long time right 15 years from
when i moved to newcastle for university
until
november 2021
i'd been there with some small
periods of
like a season in ibiza or a trip to bali
i basically been there my entire life
and i have quite a big wanderlust i have
i love traveling i love adventure
so the opportunity to go somewhere else
and still do the main thing contribute
to that is that's one of the best things
right to be able to have something that
you can pick up and move and still enjoy
all the stuff that you like about being
on holiday which is new people new
experiences novel intents blah blah but
also be able to still do the thing which
gives you that sense of um industrial
satisfaction so i'm still contributing
to my broader longer term meaning whilst
doing something which is happiness right
so you have happiness on one side you
have meaning on the other and you're
able to facilitate both so yeah it's
pretty good
lj22 during the jeffrey miller episode
he discussed the issue of cuddling
people and jeffrey posed the question
the last three times someone's broken up
with you have you asked them why
with what you have learned about today's
dating market in mind
if an amalgamated avatar of the partners
you have broken up with over time was
created and you were asked to conduct an
exit interview or debriefing with it
providing honest perhaps brutally honest
feedback about the things that were
within its control to change and
enabling it to level up future
relationships what would your advice be
this is another awesome question
right um
i think
one of the common issues that i've had
with x's has been
their um
tension between what i want to do in
life what i fundamentally feel is a
calling so usually business or personal
development
and me seeing them and this is something
that i think is mirrored in a lot of
relationships that i have with that i
see my friends in where it it feels like
the
girlfriend
sees the pursuit as the
boyfriend choosing that over them and
that is uh
from that they infer that they maybe
don't love them that much or the you
know anxieties kick in um
if you as a partner begin to get in
between
your male partner and the thing that
they think that they're on the planet to
do
it's not going to go well because
very quickly
they're going to the boyfriend is going
to begin to resent the girlfriend for
getting in the way of doing something
that isn't with that and like what are
you going to do instead especially if
it's well just come round and we'll
watch netflix and you go hang on a
second so you're saying that i can't go
and do the thing that i think i'm
supposed to do to contribute to my
highest purpose online in life
and the alternative is to go to the
cinema or go do netflix or something
like that
um
now you could say that
it's the job of the boyfriend me
to make the girl feel so comfortable
that that isn't a concern because she's
been reassured and you might be right
but that's
a
mechanism that i have consistently seen
happen and it's very very destructive to
relationships uh i would also say
that
concerns around spending time with
friends or going traveling is another
one so
you know
this again kind of comes back to the are
you paying attention to
something else instead of the girl and
them not being happy with that and then
maybe making you feel guilty about doing
that and again perhaps it's your job to
make them feel sufficiently comfortable
but i also think that
on average um this can bring up some
anxieties that kind of aren't justified
or aren't warranted um you can spend you
know
two or three nights a week with a
girlfriend that you're seeing and it's
you know in just the middle chunk of a
relationship but if you decide to spend
the other four nights with friends
you sometimes end up on the receiving
end of a lot of tension um
[Music]
those both of those things i think are
completely destructive you're making the
boyfriend choose
between
what he wants to do
and his social support
and his time with friends and you like
you're you're actually creating
a
polarity
or a um
like an enemy
uh dynamic between you and that and
that's not good you don't want
your partner to see you as the enemy of
his purpose and his friends how did you
ever actually thinking about like how
was that ever going to work
um so that's what i'd say
call campbell
what is the biggest red pill you have
swallowed in the last 12 months um
probably
the corporate press
very rarely know what they're talking
about and the people in power don't have
a clue either
uh that's maybe been the last two years
i think that
kovid has taught me more than anything
that
most of the people who are in positions
of power are just idiots all the way up
they're no better or more informed or
more
virtuous or with higher integrity or
better insight than me or you
or anybody else
they're just
fallible idiots that have managed to
make their way into a position of power
and now they're trying to say that
you're supposed to listen to them
because they're in a position of power
um and that then gets weaponized by a
media that has an agenda
so
a complete lack of
faith in mainstream media and in the
powers that be which is obviously
fantastically uplifting uh call campbell
part two what work have you done to
enable you to push back and probe more
with guests that hold more controversial
or challenging views or opinions
good question so i said last time on the
250 episode which was only
three months ago or something um
that
i was after a conversation with chris
and matt from decoding the gurus i was
really working
at trying to understand how to be more
um
more disagreeable
in episodes and be able to push back and
find holes
in the arguments of the people that i'm
speaking to
and it's a skill that you need to learn
um you know i said that that was
something i'm really working on and
that's one of the fundamental skills
that i'm trying to develop
but it's not going to come overnight
right i i you don't just make a decision
to be able to do something and then be
able to do it that being said
i
i'm starting to see in a bunch of
different episodes and in conversations
with my friends i'm practicing ways to
be able to
push back to be able to hang hang on
hang on a second hang on hang on are you
actually saying that you know just all
of these little intonations and
strategies that you have
to not destroy the conversation because
it's really difficult to like hammer
someone and then have the conversation
continue to move forward in a good faith
way because
well you've just said something that's
made them made their idea feel really
stupid or that's made them whatever
uncomfortable
doing that and continuing the flow and
continuing the rhythm of the
conversation is a genuine art form and
that's when you realize that people like
i don't know like a a rogue rogan's
pretty good at doing this that generally
when he does give pushback and pushback
can continue for a long time where it
fractures the conversation into a little
back forth back forth back forth
and then it's still amicable and stuff
as it continues to go on um that's
that's a real skill and
that's been
constantly doing that when i'm having
conversations with friends if i'm sat in
the sauna if i'm listening to another
podcast thinking all the time okay
where is uh an unsubstantiated claim
here where is something that i don't
think that they've expanded on enough
where is the term that i don't think
that they've defined
all of those
points are
they're areas i'm trying to work on
you've said hold more controversial or
challenging views or opinions
i do think that there probably is a
little bit of a responsibility to do
that up against people who are more
controversial or have challenging views
or opinions um
that being said
it's not my job to be the to say what
the audience wants to hear it's like to
ask questions that would be interesting
for the audience to hear yeah but if i
just have a day where i want to have a
conversation with somebody like we
forget this about rogan i think someone
had brought up i can't remember which
episode it was that he'd done something
and he seemed like he was really off in
the relationship with him and this
person
was one way or another you think well
maybe that or maybe he just had a bad
night's sleep or maybe he just had an
argument with his misses when he left
the house we forget that people
famous people or whatever
are people too and they have all of the
same issues that every other normal
person has so working on it in and
outside of the show and i think that
with the skill acquisition and where
it's at at the moment i think that by
the end of this year i will be
much much better at doing it and every
episode i'm i'm trying hard to do it as
well
caroline gray if you were to recommend
three other podcasts to listen to what
would they be and why okay well
you'll already listen to all of the big
ones like the tim dillons and the rogans
and stuff
so i'll try and pick three that are a
little bit
off the wall
um
the end of the world with josh clark
is
a nine part series on
existential risk one episode on
different types of x-risks so
nuclear threats or engineered pandemics
or
bioweapons or whatever
and it's beautifully soundscaped they've
got gorgeous uh
full interviews chopped up integrated
with the way that the sound
track works just beautiful really
beautiful so that's uh the end of the
world with josh clark that's great
um
the coming storm
uh on bbc radio 4's podcast which you
can get on spotify and stuff like that
that's about the q anon
um
world and how that came about and it
tracks right back to sort of the mid-90s
with bill clinton and then hillary
clinton
all the way up through january 6th
and i think that's maybe a six-part
series
something like that
that was again you can see a bit of a
trend between both of these beautifully
soundtracked um
really really lovely production
what's a final one
um
i think it's called reflecting on
history and it's got a red
red logo i think it might have the tank
from tiananmen square and it's just this
dude that breaks down like really small
podcasts but this dude breaks down
interesting stuff from history and i
really appreciate it so there's three
jonathan
oh [ __ ]
sal
dar
saldariaga
jonathan saldariaga nailed it
i loved your episode with cosmic skeptic
what are the reasons slash
justifications to keep consuming animals
and don't you see it as a moral
imperative to decrease unnecessary
suffering
i agree i do agree i think that my diet
is definitely at odds with my
uh morals at the moment because
it is unnecessary suffering i don't have
a
pushback against alex's position i think
that it's
i'm sure that there is someone out there
that would be able to find a hole in the
philosophy but
i don't think that it would compel me as
much as alex's position has
uh the main reason and i would say that
this is the reason for most people if
you were able to give them an equally
convenient equally tasty equally
nutritious diet
that reduced suffering
they would absolutely do it
the reason i don't is convenience right
it's convenience and habit and this is
what i've said to alex as well privately
that
to get more people on board with
veganism it needs to be made easier
i understand you can i'm a perfect
example of this like i'm convinced by
the philosophy that underpins it but
it's effortful for me to do it and i
don't know how i don't know what the
first steps and so on and so forth i
really think that the same way as there
is a um you know like sober october dry
january
uh i think it's like no fap
no fap november or something as well uh
there should be a if they did a vegan
month oh they do v january i suppose
don't they
that's not really very well promoted or
at least i don't think it is
that is the sort of thing introducing it
making it more easy and integrating with
people's habits i think that would make
the biggest difference
tim
is jordan peterson the same wise kind
and humble man off-camera that he is on
camera yeah like the guy's he's the real
deal and he's very attentive
very caring
he also
absolutely spanked me at topgolf
as well
which
wasn't an enjoyable experience
i arrived in san antonio with video
guiding and michaela rang and said uh
dad wants to go to topgolf but no one
else like wants to go to topgolf will
you go
sure enough fine
turned up thought
you know jordan's not that long out of
recovery and you know he's in his
like 50s or 60s that i've got to get
i've got to have this guy uh turns out
that he is uncomfortably good
at golf uh significantly better than i
am so
but i was better than video guiding
which is what's most important so there
we are
uh
yadis for real
what's one thing that no matter what you
do you still struggle with
um
i have quite a negative inner monologue
uh
the voice that's inside of my head isn't
a massively nice person sometimes or a
chunk of the time
and
that
lack of assistance uh or support
internally
uh is something that i wish that i had
um i don't know
quite where that voice comes from i am
working with
my new therapist
on this uh me and vinnie are talking
about
what
where it comes from what the sort of
uh
heritage of this is doing a bit of
archaeology but yeah i would say that
and i know a lot of people that have
this to write that
they're you know good performers or
whatever but the internal landscape is
still not
a very nice place to be
um and it's good because you go well it
motivates you to do more and you see
these people that have
unbelievable successes and
but you don't know what their internal
state is like
and that's why you should be very very
cautious about being jealous of anyone
they might have it all sorted they might
have the life they might have the house
and the career and the status and the
money
but it might not be a very nice place to
be
inside
and that's what i'm working on i am
significantly better as well you know i
can
celebrate my wins and i can support
myself and stuff but
that's still it you know like and it's
not the thing is as well
what's the one thing that no matter what
you do you still struggle with this
thing isn't the thing that will be fixed
by what i do it will be fixed by the way
that i see what i do and this is where
that imposter adaptation mechanism thing
that bro signs out of existence or into
existence
that's where that came from right that
it's
this sort of thought pattern
isn't fixed externally it's fixed
internally and
it's not about you reaching some
particular level that's then going to
fill the hole it's about you filling the
hole
and then reaching the level michael
stokes how did you get into podcasting
and how many subscribers did you have
before inviting your first guest
so i was invited onto the propane
fitness podcast probably about five
years ago ish and i really enjoyed it
and i thought that was fun i wish i
could do that more uh hang on
if i did that myself i could do it all
the time i could do as much as i want
so i
[ __ ] about for about four months
trying to come up with a name and a
brand
and some other bits and then
banked a few episodes and then released
it but literally zero zero subscribers
before inviting my first guest
and i think i had four episodes ready uh
stu my friend life hacks 101 and 102
dan bailey and um
dave castro from crossfit
i had five i had five banked before we
released anything and then
just went from there and it's now
every week at least in one form or
another
for four years which is kind of wild
when i think about it kwame
are free
congratulations on 350k thank you a lot
of the work you do is clearly intense
what
are you doing mentally and physically to
stay focused day to day
um
yeah it is it is uh intense
a big part of this is
doing things that aren't work
so
working more has diminishing returns and
this is a lesson that i learned a couple
years ago um
and it's one of the reasons why
self-care is
within the five core values that i have
because if i don't look after me i can't
do the things that other people value me
for um
mentally and physically
meditation every day
uh morning walk upon waking uh walks
regularly throughout the day to break up
in between activities before this i was
in just
later in the day and i thought right i'm
not quite in the zone to be animated and
to think about all of these questions so
i went for a little walk
like put my feet in some cold water came
back and i'm like right i'm ready to go
um training usually between five and
seven times a week um
some sessions are just turning over
listening to a podcast or you know just
chilling out not a super intense session
other sessions where i need to really
send it i'll tend to have
either a training partner or a class
just because i find it significantly
easier to
work really hard when i've got that
accountability externalized that's
something i think more people need to
realize it's not that you're struggling
to get motivation to go to the gym it's
that you're going on your own it's
really really hard to be motivated to do
anything on your own
um
other stuff mentally making sure that i
sleep again you know it's like try to
say sleep's the most important uh
recovery strategy that you've got but
focusing on sleep and spending more time
around other people as well um i
think i rely quite heavily on myself got
that single only child mentality
and
getting like forcing myself to be more
social which is easy in austin because
easier and awesome because there's lots
of things happening forcing myself to be
more social gets myself out of my own
head gets myself out of my own workspace
and then when i come back i'm actually
invigorated to come and do stuff as
opposed to it just constantly being this
like endless convey about grind so it
means that my emails get replied to
quite poorly um however
when i actually get around to doing any
bit of work i i genuinely want to
uh jake ken parker do you think going on
decoding the gurus has changed your
approach to how you conduct interviews
and if if so what have you changed the
guests since have included a few people
who'll be on the hit list do you think
you gave enough pushback so uh yes this
is similar to what i said earlier on
um
it definitely has changed my approach to
how i conduct interviews and i have a
lot to thank chris and matt for um for
doing that they highlighted that i
wasn't being sufficiently disagreeable
and
that i
need to
work on that ability to be able to push
back to not just be a mouthpiece that
allows anybody to come on and talk about
whatever they want whether their ideas
are dangerous or not it's just a more
interesting interview and a um
a more virtuous way to do a an interview
in a podcast if you do push back because
if that person cracks under pressure it
shows that their understanding of what
they were talking about is fairly
limited and
if they don't understand what they're
talking about and the pushback breaks
them then they didn't deserve to be
talking about it in any case and if the
pushback doesn't and they give a really
great answer then the audience is more
bought in to the thing that they were
saying so it's like a it's a win-win but
it is a little bit of a trial by fire
for the guests um
guests since have included a few people
who will be on their hit list yeah
probably so i think uh james o'keefe um
is probably someone that they're not a
huge fan of uh carl benjamin
i'm not sure how they feel about mary
harrington uh malice maybe their
audience has a huge problem with jordan
peterson um but again like i said
it's not
the show has done
450 episodes and i would guess that of
450
less than 50 of them
absolutely less than 100 of them but
probably less than 50 of them have been
on culture war topics
uh you know we've done
like five percent of the episode more
than five percent of the episodes of all
time have been life hacks episodes so
for uh any
critic to think that what i'm doing this
show for is to be a rabid culture
warrior that is surreptitiously sneaking
it in
under the guise of doing
10 or 20 episodes on nerdy productivity
or life hacks or self-development just
so that i get to bring my next like
alt-right troll on
i
i don't think that there's a lot of
evidence for that um
do i think that i gave enough pushback
i
do with
in certain seg sections it's difficult
to do
every single time perfectly and it's
something that i'm developing however
james o'keefe i got a bunch of messages
from people saying um i was surprised at
how much you
uh like the place that you took him to
asking questions about do you think that
you're impartial
uh what are the ethics of under
undercover recording are you sure that
you don't have people that have got my
line intent when they come and speak to
you and they try to be um
sources for your news organization uh so
i i was i felt really really happy with
how i'd done that and i didn't get any
negative comments on twitter or on
youtube or anything else about that and
i think it's a sort of episode that
people probably would have had a big
problem with
um
i i'm working hard right say what you
want it's not going to happen overnight
um but it is a skill that i'm developing
and i can see the trajectory of where
i'm going to get to and i know that i'm
doing this in good faith like i
genuinely care about doing this right
and i'm going to so
for the people that i have a problem
with the fact that i bring certain
guests on but here's another thing right
so going on decoding the gurus i knew
was going to
create a rod for my own back because i
could no longer feign ignorance about
the things that i'm not good at that
they have a problem with so as soon as i
say yeah i understand about this and
this and this
that is then a water line that i can
continually be judged up against but
until you poke your head above and
actually identify that you know about it
you can kind of always feign ignorance
and people don't
have this sense that you are now obliged
to live up to the standard that you said
you were going to try and do if that
makes sense so
i was aware that by
making
my awareness of the criticisms
public that that then makes me culpable
for
not
adhering to whatever standard
they feel or whoever
feels i should be um but i've had a
bunch of calls with chris i've spoken to
chris offline a fair bit uh and
you know for all of the criticisms
like i'm happy
with the way that i'm going
i'm happy with the direction that my
skill level is going in and yeah i'm not
at the place there's still a lot of work
for me to do on that side of things
on the disagreeability side
however like
worlds apart from where i was two years
ago worlds apart from where i was six
months ago and i know that i'm
continuing to work on it and more
important than that like i know that i
care right so
whoever it is if there's a person that
doesn't have a lot of faith it's like
okay come back in six months and see how
different it is because it will be
different and other than that like i'm
doing it for me i'm happy with the
conversations that i have um i know that
i'm doing the best that i can so
chris thompson any unknown hobbies
homemade sushi cardistry what the [ __ ]
is cardistry
cardistry is the performance art of card
flourishing unlike card magic card
history is meant to be visually
impressive and appear very hard to
execute
the term cardistry is a portmanteau
of card and artistry oh i should have
seen that coming backgammon big love any
unknown hobbies homemade sushi cardistry
backgammon big love big love to you too
chris great name um
fantasy books read a lot of fantasy
books stuff like red rising and the name
of the wind
and i'm just going to brandon sanderson
because everybody told me that i had to
on twitter um
it's most of this stuff you don't really
have
not not a cooker
i
quite enjoy
uh
history documentaries timeline world
history on youtube
is one of my most watched i'm not really
convinced that watching youtube's no
matter what it is is a hobby uh
fantasy you're gonna go fantasy give you
the same answer that i gave to take me
out
dusty green how has growing in fame or
money changed or affected you both for
the better and the worse um
well i mean the money thing is
we're not at the stage where that's
really made much difference i've kind of
swapped one income for another with
the nightlife stuff um
but
growing in fame
is kind of weird because it's
i've managed to get to what like
nano influencer level
in a very particular niche
a very particular type of person that
watches one platform of many platforms
and
it
all that i feel for the most part
is gratitude for the people that watch
like you
and uh like ambient anxiety ambient
anxiety about um what this means
or about the attention and stuff like
that that comes
something that you can do which i never
really thought of previously you you
absolutely can overshoot fame there is
certainly a thing as becoming too famous
and i'm thankfully nowhere near that and
probably never will be um but
it probably arrived sooner than you
think tim ferriss has this amazing
article i think it's called
13 reasons not to get famous
and it's fantastic
that's something that i'm very conscious
of as well that once you take that genie
out of the bottle there's no putting it
back in like once you've got too famous
you can't you can't stop that um and the
problem with
problem one of the side effects of
podcasting is that uh
the ideal scenario would be everybody
knows your name and nobody knows your
face
uh and sadly with podcasting you have
the potential reverse where everybody
knows your face and nobody knows your
name uh or some people know your name
and then maybe they know uh reddit
threads have been made about you um
it'll be interesting to see what happens
over the next year or so like i say if
you looked at the graph
of
what
the growth of the show looks like it's i
i promise you it's just flat it's flat
for two
two and a half nearly three years and
then there's tiny little wobbles because
obviously when you expand something out
to like exponential growth it looks
stupid
um
so every single thing is a new challenge
and
i don't really know i mean i know that
lex struggles at least a little bit with
this the increased attention which is
bizarre because it's what you want
because you're doing the show to reach
more people and have great conversations
but also it's kind of the sort of thing
and it also sounds like such a first
world problem but it is a challenge
right and you know speaking for myself
this month i've been very very conscious
of the increased eyes and scrutiny and
stuff and i don't really know how to
deal with it um but
i've never met a hater in real life
um
and
the people that come up say
gorgeous nice things and the messages
that you guys leave me make me feel have
a uh i've said this before i have an
album on my phone of all of the messages
that i've received even the ones
sometimes that i haven't had time to
reply to um that ben has assistant ben's
put in and i've screenshotted those and
then if i'm having a down day or if i'm
feeling like i just demotivated or i
have a period where people say bad stuff
about me on the internet i just go and
look at that and it it gasses me up so
much so thank you to
you people that do reach out uh malik is
playing to my strengths better than
working on my shortcomings
i would say
you need to get
all of your shortcomings all of the
areas of your life to the minimum
effective dose
you need to have
the
entry level
minimum amount of understanding about
all of the things that you need to be
able to do to be a functional human and
then once you've done that i would say
focus on one or two of your strengths
and just go an inch wide and a mile deep
on those because
you're not going to make as big of an
impact at being
5 out of ten on everything as you are at
being
three out of ten on everything except
for two eights or nines out of tens or
one ten out of ten um that being said
there is a risk
let's say that it's to do with health or
finances to you know good examples
if you don't give them any attention at
all you're going to be
dead or diabetic or broke very very
quickly so get yourself to the minimum
level that you need with those ones and
then absolutely focus on your strengths
that's
you don't need to be
a
jack of all trades across stuff you just
need to be a master of like one or two
sean spooner what's one question you
didn't ask a guest at the time that
you've wondered about ever since
that is a
that is a very very good question
i'm not sure
i'm gonna think about that um
i i
i'm really really happy with most of the
most of the ways that the episodes have
gone recently
i've prepped right the episodes have
flown
the flow of them has been good
um
[Music]
that's a really good question i'm gonna
have to that's the first one that's
flummoxed me and i'm gonna have to come
back to
mr robot what are your big three lift
prs while it depends on whether or not
you're talking about crossfit total or
powerlifting total i'm going to presume
that you mean powerlifting total uh
deadlift is 210 kilos
bench press is one 45 kilos
squat
one
i haven't tested my one rep max squat in
as long as i can remember
probably one six five one 170
back injury hasn't been very nice with
squats
floop c what's your favorite thing about
michael mallis
how much he has supported me and invited
me to meet new people since i've been in
austin
chris rubio i have a question for you
chris good i'm here
what makes you think it's a wise idea to
refer to subscribers to your channel as
cult members does this imply that you're
the leader
fair question um i don't know where that
came from i think someone
started talking about a wisdom cult
um
and i sort of
went with that i'm kind of thinking of
starting wisdom cult merch
it's kind of a cool name i quite like
the idea of
a positive or a holistic cult
i think hamza has got a similar idea to
me as well like around the idea that
most cults are seen as bad things but
the buy-in that you get from people
the only reason it's bad is because of
the outcome the buy-in that you get from
people could actually be used for good
uh does it imply that i'm leader i have
no idea i i don't think through
everything um
that much
however
maybe i should
say something else
of all of the nefarious things that i
could call people like a completely
arbitrary term that talks about a group
being uh
adhered together um
i don't think cult members is that bad
however i'm open to alternatives uh but
i do want to have more meme content
around the channel zack's so good at
this right he memes first and then
explains later so
uh
i am going to try and do a bit more of
that i mean that comes out in the locals
community a bit but
it's hard to have in-jokes when it's
only you as the host and the guests
always change uh so having some
consistent sort of terminology is is
kind of funny and useful and makes
people feel like they belong
but i don't know cult members was just
something that came out um
what makes you think it's a wise idea i
i'm i'm unsure i'm aware that this is
modern wisdom but
it is what it is we might change that
hey chris i really appreciate your
podcast and deep conversations you have
on them from alexander uh what are some
of the effects of being well known that
people might not think about it seems
more commonplace today but i think it's
a bit unusual to have a hundred thousand
plus people know what you look like and
know about you it could be a bit
overwhelming to have many people contact
you too
this is what i was saying before like
there is such a thing as being too
famous and again nano influence of me is
absolutely not there but
some of the effects of being
well known
one of them is that you
very rarely are you questioning your own
motivations and thought patterns and the
things that you say in the ways that you
say them
unless you're saying them with an
audience that's them watching
and the degree of
self-scrutiny and self-doubt perhaps
this is
led into a little bit by the internal
monologue that i've got in my own mind
but
you scrutinize the things that you say a
lot more because you know that they're
going to be rigorously tested by the
whatever 100 000 people 350 000 people
that you're talking to
and yet it is
it's a strange thing we're not designed
for this many people to know who we are
we're not designed for this many people
to pay us attention and
i i did a newsletter this week which you
can sign up for if you go to
chriswilex.com um
i did a newsletter talking about how
fame used to be a signal for you having
done something virtuous and now it's
kind of this
um hollow
vapid uh
end in itself people used to want to be
famous because it was a signal of you
having done something now people want to
be famous just to be famous it's
obligation-free status
and
[Music]
it's not the thing that everybody wants
in fact it's not the thing that most
people should desire to want
um it's only a very particular
type of person again you see this with
lex right like he's someone that spends
16 hours a day programming and building
robots and wants to try and change the
world with you know doing this
his programming in his robotics
and then whatever like
probably a hundred and two hundred or
five hundred million people have watched
the stuff that he does what how is he
supposed to think about that
um and again who's going to say oh
poor influencers on the internet they
should or podcasters or youtubers or
whatever look at them they've got it so
hard yeah i i am aware that
it's not
it's like the most first world problem
sympathy to ask for um
but it is it is a a strange beast and i
i'm gonna continue to try and be as open
as possible as i go through this growth
here's another thing right
most people that are famous
even if it's famous with a trajectory
from when you can see when they weren't
famous so not like justin bieber fame
where he's always been famous and he's
like a hyper star i'm talking you know
jordan peterson or
someone like that where you there was a
world where he wasn't and now there's a
world where he is and you've been able
to track his progression through all of
that
i don't think that
most people see those people as people
they don't see someone like joe rogan or
jordan peterson as an actual person they
see them like a representation of ideas
and this is one of the reasons why
people are prepared to say
such crazy things on the internet like i
don't know about
you
i have never
written out some awful
horrible comment to send to someone in
vitriol on the internet
uh unless it's like i've said much worse
things to my friends than i have to my
to to randoms
and
people forget that
people are people no matter how many
subscribers or followers they've got you
know all of these news stories and
analyses and reaction videos and stuff
like that we think like there is another
person on the other side of this and the
internet has dehumanized much of
humanity
and the people who garner the most
attention are the ones that dehumanize
the most and the ones that have the most
scrutiny and the ones that get the most
attention and the ones that have the
most messages incoming and comments
it's not
like the haven that fame
promised everyone like that's something
that i think me and everybody as well
should remember i think the the most
popular
job
for
primary school kids now is youtuber
you're like
if you hit a million subs or if you hit
you know a couple of million subs you
might regret your decision and you can't
really put that genie back in the bottle
johann manuel gasser
great name you have inspired me to not
drink for a while it's been almost two
months since my last beer brother
congratulations well done that's amazing
stick at it stick at it for six months
and see where you get to
lisa what does an ideal date look like
for you not in terms of the person but
the places activities topics of the
conversation etc
walking date walking date is one of the
best things that you can do because it's
short you can do it during a lunch break
or whatever you're kind of moving and
because you're unless you're one
person's walking backward facing the
person that's working for walking
forward um
you're going to be side by side which
makes it a little bit less intense it
means that there's always new stuff to
talk about or to comment on uh you know
you can people watch which is fantastic
and
everybody needs to be interested in
people watching there'll be nature
you'll keep moving and if the date's a
complete disaster
it's what like a half hour walk and you
can you know you can just say oh so see
there and do whatever that i think is
one of the best
ways to start
conversation
a little bit different
like it's very dependent on what that
person is um but
the bottom line is if you want the other
person to feel
like you care and if you actually like
them just ask questions right just find
out about that person you already know
everything that you have to say
and you know nothing that they're gonna
have to say
so one of the most selfless things sorry
one of the most selfish things that you
can do in a conversation is be selfless
um robert l
simple one are you ever starstruck by
the people you meet and if so how do you
deal with it um
that that's
kind of quickly being worn down i think
i spoke about this last time um there's
a friend of mine who did an interview
with a famous academic and before he
started this academic got up went to the
fridge and got a muller corner out my
friend watched this academic from across
the room peel the lid off the yogurt
look at it
and then lick the lid of the yogurt and
at that moment he his entire mystique
dispelled and since then
every person that i've met has had a
yogurt-lid moment for me too which kind
of dispels the mystique and it reminds
me that they're a real person which is
also what the internet sort of
dehumanizes because you never get to see
that um
so i've kind of rolled that out across
everyone i met scott alexander from
slate star codex now astral codex 10 a
couple of weeks ago he's just a dude you
know he's a guy that needs to
tie his shoelaces and put his pants on
and and have a shave and stuff he's just
a dude all of these people are just
people um
so
i don't know it
it gets easier
like exposure therapy
it gets easier uh
himalaya herb
hey chris i subscribed to your channel
when you were around 5k
you've been here for a long time glad to
see how it's going up congrats what if
you had kept the name modern wisdom how
many subs would you have i liked modern
wisdom anyways good luck with the
channel you have a fantastic channel
thank you um
so yeah the change was
even less than a year ago now uh we went
from modern wisdom to chris williamson
i just i had people arriving on the
channel saying this is really good
who the [ __ ] is the host there is no way
that someone should be landing i've
managed to get them from the annals of
youtube finally to get them onto a
podcast and them not know who i am um so
personal accountability which is a naval
thing plus the fact that
i wanted to be able to have
conversations that i wanted to do that
weren't held to the trappings of
whatever the podcast was and if i want
to do non-podcast content like down the
pipe monologue videos
is it going to be easy with my name and
blah blah blah so yeah i think we
actually lost subs for a month
because a ton of people presumably went
on the subscription feed and we're like
who the [ __ ] is chris williamson i'm not
subscribed to him uh and then
unsubscribed uh which was unfortunate
but then we kind of picked back up which
was good
have you been to or said the word
newfoundland
and if so i'd bet 10 000 subscribers you
didn't say it right also absolutely love
the show and everything you're doing man
newfoundland
i'm going to see
if there is a
oh
this is a word
this is a word that you pronounce
in a very different way to the way that
it's spelled which is stupid because it
absolutely says
new found land and i don't think that
like those are three words that already
exist and i don't think
newfoundlanders that you get to say
how it's said
newfoundland is newfoundland and i will
fight any man that says otherwise
k
s t k saint or k street
enjoyed your newsletter if fame was
bestowed on those that earned it through
something special do you now look back
on love island with contempt appreciate
where you
now is incredible in comparison to where
you were then possibly love you man
chris thank you um no i don't look back
in it with contempt i do think that
there are some concerns that i have
around
what it teaches young people about
success that the goal is basically to be
plucked out of obscurity and given
status
versus working hard
consistently at something which adds
value over a long period of time i would
much sooner love island i know
be across an entire year and then be
highlights of all of the things that
those people had done or whatever but
it's not like
you again we can't put this genie back
in the bottle as soon as you're going to
have obligation free status where people
just get
picked like one of those claw machines
in an arcade and just like you you get
to go and be
blue taking and millions of followers in
a brand deal with pretty little thing
that's not gonna stop um
i look back on it i i don't look back on
it with contempt at all i look back on
you know i can't change that i look at
sort of modern
current love island with a little bit of
trepidation uh and i think that we
should be careful about what it teaches
young people about success
how are the lads who would win in a
fight between johnny and youssef
ah that's a very good question i think
i think just based on sheer size you
know johnny would be two or three weight
categories above yousef um that being
said youssef does
tricking
flips and acrobatic kicks
as a hobby um and
johnny is uh built for power not speed
so
if yusuf could get him past the first
couple of rounds i'm pretty confident
youssef's got him however if johnny
grabs a hold of him uh within that game
over
varrick stormblest you sound like a
character in a fantasy book uh what
things have you changed your opinion on
in the last two years due to new
information slash insight the more
political the better
ah dude i i really don't think about
politics stuff that much like here's a
good insight as well actually
ben's
pulled a bunch of questions out that
were kind of repeats but this is a
pretty broad cross-section of all of the
stuff right that people who listen to
this channel are interested in
none of them have been about politics
none of them have been about [ __ ]
trans agenda or about the next new woke
sjw that's trying to take over things
all it is is people that are interested
in bettering themselves so that
makes me feel very very good however
varick um
one of the things that i would say is
my distrust of
governments and politicians at large i
think it's very difficult for anybody
that's been through the last couple of
years with a skeptic ally to have come
out of this with your trust of those
intact
pretty much everybody even the people
that are pro
the
governmental and mainstream media
lines
on things i think even they are doing it
with a
point in the back of their minds
thinking well yeah like okay i'm saying
it but maybe that's just because i agree
with it but i don't believe them like i
just happen to fall in line with the
thing that they're saying
uh so that distrust of that and distrust
of the media those are the two that i've
really really pivoted on um
the abortion debate i
really do not i can't find a firm place
to stand
um
like both
sides have very compelling arguments
and i really struggle
to find a firm place to stand with that
and i i wish that i did
have i wish that i could
just commit
commit to something with with regards to
it but i find it a very difficult
argument to
to get around it it feels like the
empathetic position is both sides
um
very strange but yeah that would be it
uh distrust of government distrust of
media
and a complete lack of knowledge about
my position on uh abortion
berto
consalvi
what is the best piece of advice you
would give another person
that you do not follow yourself
that is awesome
[Music]
um get off social media
probably
if you don't need it for work get off
social media um i'm pretty sure that
it's a net negative for almost everybody
and it's probably going to make you
much more attractive to whoever it is
that you're with
uh or to prospective mates think about
this right you go out for a date with a
person whoever it is
and you say oh could you let's you meet
them in the gym or something you go out
for a date with them pick your sex of
choice that you're attracted to and then
when you're talking you say so what do
you do and blah blah blah and then
before you leave oh can you give me your
instagram so i can have a look and they
say i don't i don't have social media
and you go what
yeah i don't i don't have social media i
don't i
i don't really see the appeal of it i i
don't really like wasting my time
that person's cool as [ __ ]
whoever they are that person's very very
cool and very very intriguing so apart
from the fact that i think it's a like a
nice flex for dating uh just get off
social media you don't need it you do
not need it get your news from elsewhere
steven
sperling what gives you the most hope
the fact that we have democratized the
ability for people to take control of
their own lives the fact that i know
based on myself and my friends and
the people that i admire
that it is possible to take yourself
from a place where you don't
particularly like the person that you
are
and you don't feel like you add a
massive amount of value to a place where
you really really do
and that is one of the most inspiring
stories that i think that we can give
people and it's what most people are
hoping for and searching for in the
modern world
and
the more people that do that and open
and break the fourth wall about their
experience of doing it
the more the other people are going to
try and do it as well
and there's far more mystique you know
if you have the
whatever the perfect brand managed
existence where
it's
you're doing speaking stages at
conventions and there's all this
mystique around how how your process
works and stuff like that that's great
and it works for some people you know
like whatever the tony robbins it's like
people of the world
but and it also makes you um more
fallible or it makes you more open to
critique because people actually know
stuff about your private life or about
your personal life um but the more that
people are open about this i think the
better that it is because it that's
genuinely what inspires people it's very
difficult to see yourself in
tony robbins
right like what what's the
like line of that or like a justin
bieber or something like that justin
bieber's come up a favor today however
alex or
uh a rogan or whatever someone where you
can track
that lineage
seems like a more inspiring story
uh
simon
barroll
which person now dead do you wish you
could have interviewed on your podcast
that's a good question so johnny's got
this answer to this where
he wants to have his
uh
great grandparents um at dinner you know
you say
pick five people alive or dead to go for
dinner with and he would just pick a
bunch of his grandparents and great
grandparents that he didn't get a chance
to meet until he was like
while he was a kid or they were dead
before he was alive
i would really quite like to uh
interview i'd
almost all of my grandparents i haven't
been able to have a relationship with so
i would really love to speak to one of
them because i think that you learn a
lot from
your own
genes you're going to learn far far more
about yourself from having a
conversation with somebody who has like
125th of the genetics that are inside of
you then
martin luther king or something so yeah
i would pick uh
one of my grandparents
how do you navigate thinking about your
mortality do you ever feel dread or fear
in that regard from robert isaac
so not very much for me
sometimes i do but not very much for me
but i certainly feel it for other people
like my mum and my dad uh
again you know there's no one else
around it's like i've got brothers or
sisters that are going to be able to
assist me when that happens
um so i kind of fear
um
[Music]
being alone
when that happens i'm not going to look
forward to
the
experience of having to let go of the
only
two other
living
people that share my genetics like that
are part of my family so that's gonna
that that's something that i feel dread
and fear in for sure
gay cal droko
gay khal drogo
carl you win uh username of the day
what advice would you give to the bottom
of the barrel a 24 year old neat in the
cell who wants to get himself on track
so i had to learn what neat was i only
learned this a little while ago uh that
is not in
education employment or training i think
uh 24 year old neet in cell who wants to
get himself on track
uh okay so
i would be tempted if you can to change
as much about your environment and your
routine as possible and one of the
easiest ways to do that would be to
change your location so
if you can
if your country is twinned with another
country or it has a
workers permit
that
uh
let's say like part of the european
union or whatever or in america
up sticks
go so i would try and work if you can to
get as much money as you need to be able
to go and move
and just go somewhere new and try and
reinvent yourself everybody remembers
what it was like um or maybe this is
just me when you came back after the
summer holidays and you're like yeah i'm
going to be this new person i'm going to
have had all of these experiences and
everyone's going to forget about like
the old weird nerd that i was last year
and then you try and reinvent yourself
um the fresh slate that you get when you
get to go somewhere new is a genuine
thing so i would be tempted to change
location change environment change
routine change friend group find people
that are like the sort of person that
you want to be so if you want to be the
sort of person that's into health and
fitness go to a gym crossfit or any sort
of group based class is amazing because
it's a ready-made social group for you
i would also be tempted if you can
to try and start working at something to
do with nightlife again like i'm using a
bit of availability bias here but
you will have a ready-made group of
people who are all into the same things
as you who will look after you on nights
out who will organize staff parties who
will get you
into the rhythm of being social um so
those are some ways that you can
socially sort of hack your life you will
gain friends simply by being around
these situations nightlife
especially if you can work in it uh even
if it's as a barman you know working as
a barman or a glass collector or
something like that
easy easy way to find new friends and to
be forced into being social but it's
still kind of on your terms
uh training in a gym that has group
classes and a community also amazing uh
changing location and
looking at changing your routine as well
and that will come out of new location
and new job
uh
how do you think
how do you think how you started your
career love island nightclub appearances
etc has shaped yourself now whether that
be with your career your attitude to
work etc so
one of the things was
i when i was younger
between 18 and 25
pretty much all i did was work
i
was
very much
obsessed with
working
and being productive and the success of
my business and although
a lot of the things that are useful at
one stage of your career end up being
the problems that you have to deal with
later in your career so
i have to now learn to let go of that
compulsion to work i work a lot and i i
need to
um
i'm getting better at it but work less
that being said
of the two of having to restart the
engine or kickstart the engine for the
first time at the age of 34
having never worked really really really
hard before in my life
versus
having done it when i was in my 20s and
habituated it i'm very very happy that
that was something that i did so if i
was in my 20s i would find a
working pattern a cadence
that is
hard
and that is effective because that is
the thing that you're going to that's
going to carry you through for the rest
of time the job will change the location
will change the position will change the
salary will change the thing that won't
change is your requirement to actually
do some work and be able to work hard
and to know that you've got limits that
are way way way beyond what you need to
do if you need to do 3am finishes seven
nights in a row you know that you've got
it in the tank because you've done it
before and that's kind of like a
superpower because most of the people
don't have that most of the people have
never taken themselves to a place where
they've had to get something in they've
had to do so much work that they can't
believe
that there's there's no way that they
would be able to to complete it and you
know that you've got that capacity
that's a superpower it's a real strength
so
inculcating a hard work habit when i was
young was
very useful that's one of the most
important things the rest of this stuff
was kind of a bit surface level and
didn't hasn't stuck with me all that
much
some understandings of how marketing
works and
um
brand creation and and getting people
excited to kind of be a part of a thing
and be a part of a movement and stuff
like that uh that's kind of useful i
suppose but the most important thing i
think was the habituated work ethic
how long have we been going
an hour and 32 minutes
wow
okay
um
i'll do a couple more i'll do a few more
uh if the goal is to be happy and
fulfilled being single should one just
give up on relationships uh no the goal
is to be happy being single
and not need a relationship that the
relationship's supposed to add to your
life not become your entire life
jamie bolem 866 what would need to
happen for you to look back in 10 years
time and think that your 30s have been a
success you're a smart man jamie it's a
good question
taken right out of the playbook of me
asking other people this awkward
question um
i think that
a family would be one of them i think
that i would like to have a family by
the end of my 30s and dog or dogs
and
to be proud of the body of work that
i've done
and to not have
there's this awesome quote from eminem
um that i put in my newsletter again go
to chriswellx.com to sign up to it i'm
not not talking about it because it's
[ __ ] it's really really good the best
free newsletter on the internet um
yeah
eminem was done in this interview a
little while ago and he was talking
about the fact that
he
where was it there it is in a 1999
interview eminem said i ain't in this
for the money i'm in here for the
respect if i had a trillion dollars and
i fell off i'd be the most miserable
person in the world he grew up in
poverty yet favored status over money
that's a rob henderson
drop and
that's kind of something that i feel a
little bit as well that
i wouldn't look back on a body of work
that i'm proud of and that had an impact
and that made people's lives better and
and this isn't just me saying it because
it's like the cool thing to say that is
the most fulfilling part of doing any
project right that you feel like you're
leaving the world in a better place than
when you arrived
and [ __ ] man like i can't think of
anything else to do that what else am i
going to do with my time i genuinely
don't know what else it's going to be so
hopefully by the end of my 30s
the world will be slightly less [ __ ]
like a nano meter less [ __ ] because of
whatever work i've done
um i still have we cut this down and
i've still got so many i might do
i might do i'm gonna put a line here
um
i might do a 300k
subscriber episode after the 350 uh just
because of how many more questions there
are i'm not even halfway through
the ones that we cut back
uh so
uh thank you to everyone i'm gonna leave
it there thank you to everyone that has
tuned in and supported the channel like
honestly it's it's blown my mind the
last 28 days and for all of my concerns
around increased scrutiny and stuff like
that it's
it's fantastic uh
don't forget sign up for the newsletter
chriswoleks.com
books free list of everything that we
talk about big episodes coming up if you
know jocker willink uh
loop me in with him if you want to send
in uh requests and guest suggestions
chriswellx.comcontact
and video guy
assistant ben will go through all of
those uh and in the meantime
cult members
in the long grass wearing a flowy white
dress dancing around a flagpole
we're here
peace what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you